madame monsieur bonsoir il nous a fait
rire sourire et rêver il n'a réalisé que
trois ou quatre films à succès et
pourtant son nom appartient depuis
longtemps déjà à la grande tradition du
cinéma français un cinéma où personnage
solitaire insatisfait il occupait une
place bien à part Jacques Tati vient de
mourir à l'âge de 75 ans Monsieur HULLOT
mon oncle et tous ces personnages lui
survivent France roche déjà le fait
vivre pour nous j'ai
voulu euh amener un
sourire sautoriser quand
même et je crois être un des
rares
cinéaste à accepté que les gens
parlent pendant la projection
euh qu'il soit libre
le monde entier c'était monsieur HULLOT
un personnage à mchemin entre le dessin
et la réalité farfelu et apparemment
inoffensif mais sa seule présence était
polémique il se voulait l'homme libre au
milieu des cités forteresses le poète au
milieu des stéréotypes il connut trois
carrières celle d'abord de clown
acrobatique surgissant sur les scènes de
musicol en patin roulette son premier
numéro en 33 était une parodie de tous
les sports box équitation football
tennis son corps était aussi agile que
son imagination de
gagman il y a toujours enfin je veux
dire dans les films à
prétention comique il y a toujours un
effort physique de toute façon que voyez
au volant d'une voiture ou que vous
pédaler sur une bicyclette vous devez
d'abord vous occuper d'un cheval vous
devez d'abord bien monter un cheval en
plus vous devez être un assez bon
cycliste il est certain que dans tout ce
qui est visuel
au cinéma il y a un apport physique et
le sport sert
énormément sa seconde carrière fut celle
de réalisateur il commença par le
court-métrage en finançant lui-même ses
films un de ces court-métrag tourné en
couleur plus allongé aux dimensions d'un
film d' 1h30 et tiré en noir et blanc
d'argent fut refusé par toutes les
salles une représentation surprise
improvisée dans un petit cinéma de ne
est un trium le film sort il est
couronné à Venise et remporte le Grand
Prix du cinéma français en revanche
les vacances de Monsieur hullo puis mon
oncle valent à Tati un succès
international la France écriton à son
chapeline une sorte d'anarchiste
misanthrope ronchonneur et fleurs bleu
mais vient l'automne de sa carrière Tati
dont les films sont moins rentable voi
les producteurs devenir plus
rares et puis les clown font moins rire
quand ils sautent moins vite et moins
haut l'âge est venu sa santé s'altère il
préside des festivals on lui rend des
hommages ainsi en mai dernier
mais il ne tourne plus cependant son nom
restera sur l'écran sopie sa fille a
pris la relève
courmj des pr don pu
[Musique]
mentir le Premier ministre et le
ministre de la Culture salu l'un et
l'autre la mémoire de Jacques le cinéma
français lui doit beaucoup déclare
monsieur